サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナササナナン
はい それではよろしくお願いします
で あの 今日は初めてこういう講演会に参加なさっている方々もいらっしゃると思います
あの びっくりするかもしれませんし
がっかりするかもしれませんしね
よくわからないんだけど
内容はもしかすると理解できるかどうかもちょっとわからない
で あの表面的にはすごい単純なテーマなんですけど
これはこのお釈迦様がそのような問題はどのように見るのかっていうね
ところは日本の皆様方に紹介していこうかなという働き
仕事ですね ちょっとお釈迦様の知恵っていうのはかなりけた違いもので
一般常識的に誰だって知ってることっていうのはなかなか語らないんですね
ちょっと超越した世界
真理を語っていて まあでもそれはこの理性のある人にはちゃんと理解できる
立証 立証 立証できる科学的な事実すべて
科学や物理科学ではなくて
精神科学のに立証できるものすべてを語っているんですね
だから最初にね お経のお戒を授けたり
慈悲の瞑想したりとかね
このなんか宗教のようなものをやっているんだけど
それは宗教ではありません
なんか似ている そこら辺似ているかもしれませんだけど
これは人間なら誰だってこのように生きた方がいいんじゃないんですか？と常識的に考えてみてください
ね 殺生しない方が殺生するよりは立派でしょうしね
盗むよりは盗まない人格がよろしいでしょうし
ですから そこら辺は宗教ではないんです
だから 祈りのような聞こえた慈悲の瞑想も
念じるならばこの内容を念じてくださいと
神に念じるんじゃなくて
だからそこら辺も宗教のように見えるんだけど
結局は宗教的なものではなく
理性的な生き方なんですね
はい そこら辺は十分理解したということで
テーマに入ります 今日のテーマは一応この計画する人生
流されるように生きるという 2つの正反対のことを
ブッダの智慧から考えてみましょうということで
でも私が一つ失敗しました
まあどうせ来る方々は毎回毎回来る同じグループではないかと思っちゃってね
ちょっと難しい内容を入れてしまったんだけど
一番問題は 結論から始めるんです
あべこべです ね 結論のタイトルは How long is your life? これ直訳できませんだけどね
何年生きられるというね
あなたの寿命はどれぐらい長いのかというね
それが結論なんです これは何を隠そう
これは私はパクったアイデアなんです
誰からパクったのかというと
自分のスリランカでカトリック教の伝道師がいるんですね
神父さんではないんだけどね
この伝道師 伝道師が全国的に自分の伝道活動をしているんです
参加する人々のだいたい 95%は仏教の人々なんです
で 彼の講演会は紹介して作るのもほとんど仏教の人々なんです
稀にキリスト教 カトリック教の人々も彼を紹介してね
講演やる場合もあります
講演と言ったっても まあコンサートですね
で コンサートでスリランカの伝統的な
伝統的なスリランカで昔から我々が歌っている
20年  30年前からね
その歌だけで使って ものすごい真理を
生き方を教えているんですね
だからほとんど歌は仏教的に書かれているんだから
彼の説法は結局は仏教か何教かよくわからない
結構人気はあるんですね
彼がその一つの講演会で言った一つのポイントはね
まあこれなんですね 彼のポイントは Life is program just for one day only ということなんです
命って一日だけやと これは結局お釈迦様の言葉なんです
これは訳したんですかね
人生のプログラムが一日で終了するんですね
私に明日はないでしょうと観察して生きるように
自分の人生のプログラムを実行する人は
悩み苦しみなく幸福に生きるのです
だから 私たちの問題は
目標とか計画を立てて生きようかどうか
そんなことじゃなくてね
まあせっかく生きているんだから
楽しく幸福で穏やかで安穏で微笑んで生きていきたいんです
悩みたくはない 落ち込みたくはない
負けたくはない ストレス溜まるのは嫌なんですね
だから安穏に穏やかに生きていきたいというね
そういう目的はみんなにある
だったら あんた今日しか生きられませんよと思ってくださいと
プログラムはすべて今日一日に作ってください
本当はそういうふうにできているんです
私たちはこの 10年計画
20年計画 将来の計画はあるんです
だったら この 1年に 1 年間使えるように
使用できるように一回歯を磨いてみてください
一回歯を磨いたら まああと 1 年でできる
あるいは朝ごはんを食べて
はい これから 10 年間朝ごはんを食べなくてもいいんです
これ 今食べたものは 10 年間続くと
使用期限は 10年とかね
できる 服を買って服を着て
これ使用期間は 5年ですからね
5 年間そのまま使う 最低 1週間分
2週間分お風呂に入ることできる
結局わかるでしょ？今日に限っちゃう
今日お風呂に入ったら今日だけ
明日また入らなくちゃいけない
歯磨くことも まあ健康を考える人は
まあ食後歯を磨かなくちゃあかんだけど
最低一回だけでもね 毎日やらなくちゃいけない
そういうわけで 我々の人生
何見ても一日に限ったプログラムなんです
そこを見てみれば 今日のテーマでは喋ることは何もなくなっていくんで
計画立てるか立てないでどうでもいいんです
今日だけだから だからさらにあの伝道師のね
いろいろポイントを借りていますけど
まあ私に関係ないんだけど
彼が言うのは まあこのまあほとんど家にいないんですね
まあ全国を回ったり 外国いろんな国々回ったり
しているんだからね 家を出る時は
もし戻れないかも そこで死んでしまうかもという感じで行くんだと
だったらすごい愛情いっぱいで奥さんに挨拶して別れて出て行くんです
子供一人がいるんだけど
子供にもね すごい愛情いっぱいで
では行きますと もしかすると帰られない
帰られないかも 途中で死ぬかもしれませんと
そういうことを延々と語って
この毎日ね 愛に満ちた人生を歩みましょうという
カトリック教のキリスト教のテーマを出してるんですね
でも そのテーマを立証するために
すべて仏教の話を彼がパクっていて
私は彼の話をパクってとかね
お互いパクりまくっているんです
一日だけ生きてみなさいと
過去に悩むなよと 将来に期待するなよっていうのは
お釈迦様の教えなんですね
そうすると ものの見方に頭が咲いてくるんです
やることは中途半端でやらない
人にこんにちはと言うと
精一杯こんにちはと言うんです
ありがとうと言えば 精一杯感じてありがとうと言うんです
子供がお母さん作ったご飯は
もう牛のように食うな来るんではなくて
これ食べたらもう二度とお母さんの料理食べられないかも
私は何かで死ぬかもと思ったら
心いっぱいでお母さんありがとう
美味しかったと言うでしょう
そのような人生だったら
どれほど幸せ どれほど楽しい
旦那さんが会社に出る時はね
奥さんにまあ 2度と帰らないかもという気持ちで
言いたいことを全部感謝の気持ちを込めて
はい 感謝して出ていくと
そこでお互い様 素晴らしい幸せでしょ
途中で事故 車に挟まれて
電車に挟まれて あるいは何とかで死んだっても
死ぬ時は悔しくないんで
みんなに私は正しく別れを告げて
日々幸福に生きてきたんだと
そういうことで テーマはこういう風になるんです
成功 幸福 人生の目的に達したいと思う人は
1 日で終了する計画を立てて生きるんです
はい それで結論です はい
これから皆様居眠りしたければどうぞ
途中で逃げたくなったらもう自由です
ポイントは説明しました
はい 中身に入ります 流されるように生きるということ
表面的な意味を通して中身の発見
だから流されるように生きているって
なんとなく我々は否定的に見ているんですね
本当にそうでしょうか？と
恵まれている 最高にラッキーということでね
コインを 100回投げたら 70%以上自分の狙い通り
強力な前号の下で生まれたことに確信がある
私はものすごい恵まれて生まれたんだよと
苦労して勉強しないが
試験は最優秀で合格する
勉強はそれなりにはしていますけど
学校の授業だけとかね
でも合格すると このような人がいれば
人生を計画する必要はありませんね
別になんでの方が行くんだから
意図的に計画を立てて立てるより
流されるように生きると決めた方が良い
だからハチャメチャ計画を立てるんじゃなくて
自分の幸福に自信がある
自分が超ラッキー だったら別に考えて計画を立てる必要はないんですね
皆様の中でもね そういう方がいるならば
まあ自由に生きてみてください
はい それからちょっと深みに入ります
法則は絶対的です これ正しいんですけど
太刀打ちできない 逆らうことはできない
あの言葉はすごい勢いで昨日書いたんだから
ものすごい漢字間違いとかあるかもしれませんが
その時はちょっと教えてください
はい この法則っていうのは
我々にはどうすることもできない
すべていくつかの法則によって成り立っている
この最近のね カトリック教のキリスト教の方々も
神神っていうのは この僕
昨日ネットでいろいろ説法を聞いてたんですけど
キリスト教のね で 説法を聞いていたら
もうやっぱり神という人とか害ですね
英語で言えばね もうではなくて
この全体的な法則のことやと
それだったら別に仏教は逆らう必要ないんですね
問題は 彼らがこの法則を人格化しているんですね
それから勘違いしちゃって
人に当たるんです 神様は何か私に何とかくださいとかね
それはおかしい 神様 私の病気治ってください
医者じゃないんだけどね
法則ですからね 法則だと本当に理解しているならば
バカな祈りはやめると思いますね
彼らが言っていることは
仏教の環境の場合はね
仏教に非難されますからね
いろいろごまかしして逃げますけど
全部一貫しないんですね
私が今前言った伝道の人は
できるだけ一貫して教えをしているんですね
カトリック教のグループで自分の講演がある場合は
かなり神のことを出しますけど
もうほとんどもう 95%仏教の人々のところでやっているんだから
まあ宗教は出さないで
法則だけ語って 愛 愛に満たした言い方をしましょうと
その場合 愛という言葉は使わない
慈悲という言葉を使うんですね
仏教の言葉 そこで法則っていうのは
このまあすごい難しいんだけど
さささっと書いちゃったんですよ
みんな聞いて聞いて もう嫌になっているポイントなんですね
4つあります まあ注釈書では 5つって言うんだけど
本当は 4つなんですね
1 カルマという法則 カルマというのは業
業っていうのは 我々普通は運命とか言ってる
なんか自分の生き方は決まってるんですね
その法則 それは変えられない
変えることできないんだからね
自分の運命わからないでしょうに
だから占いに聞かなくちゃいけない
あの人たちはまるっきり完璧
詐欺師でインチキで嘘ばっかりよ
それから新興宗教も金儲かるために
俺は業を知ってるやと
お釈迦様 これは誰にも知らないんだと
ブッダしか知らないんだから黙っていなさいと言ってるんです
難しいんです 宇宙法則だからね
私が知り尽くしてるよと
よく言うこと 例えば科学者すら宇宙法則をすべて知り尽くしているよと言わない
2番目 心の法則 心っていうのは自分に法則があって
それによって活動しているんです
3番目 うつうつというのは自然界ですね
いわゆる物質的な法則
地球のことやら太陽のことやら
あれやこれやとかね 宇宙の環境ですね
なんじゃ 4番目はビージュですね
これは種というふうに訳しなくちゃいけないんだから
種なんですね 種 種の現代的に言えば
遺伝子の法則ですね 例えば遺伝子のこと
皆さん知ってますね 遺伝子って自分勝手じゃない
我々の勝手で動かないね
遺伝子は遺伝子で勝手なプログラムを持っているんですね
どうすることもできない
はい この 4つでこの命をができているんです
この 5番目の法則というのはダンマニアマターというんですね
ちょっと単語すらちょっと変わります
これはパーリ経典の中にしか見られそうで
ものでという法則も説かれています
これはまず私の解釈では
この 4つにまとめたら
4つを一言葉にまとめると
ダンマニアマタ ダンマっていうのは世の中のありさまなんですね
その決定性とか何とかとは漢訳ありましたけどね
確率性 決定性とはニアマターの場合だね
ダンマっていうのは法ですからね
何でもダンマに入りますね
しかし 中作僧で このブッダだけに限った
全然一般人に理解できない
いくつチェックあるんですね
ブッダという人格者 人
普通の人間とは全く違うものをいくつか持っているんですね
お釈迦様はそれを真理の法則だと
人生はこの法則という 4つの糸で編んだロープのようなものです
だから 例えば 4つの糸があって
そこで大きいロープを編む
編んだら自分なんです
自分というのはラベルだけです
瓶の外に貼るラベルだけなんです
自分というのはね で これ伊藤さんロープなんですね
これは 4つの糸を編んでいるんですね
私たちのわがまま 自我
勝手な計画によって法則を負けることは不可能です
だから ラベルを貼ってからラベルにロープを合わせることはできないんです
我々それをやっているんです
例えば 瓶に ゴマ油を入れる
入れてラベルを貼る ハチミツと
ラベルを貼ってみたらハチミツなんですけど
中身は違うんだから これ何とかしなくちゃとかね
これはありえないんですね
自分がハチミツと勝手にラベルを貼っても
瓶の中に入れるのはゴマ油なんです
だから我々は自我というラベルを貼って
このラベルに合わせて人生変えよう
変えようとしているんですね
だから これいい加減やめなさいなんです
あんた困るんだったら
一番簡単なことは何でしたっけ？ラベルを外すぞ
そうすると中身に対して困る必要はないんです
中を見たら あ ゴマ油ですねと決められますね
また他の瓶を開けてみたら
わからないね ラベルないんだから
開けてみたら あ ハチミツだ
それで困らない ハチミツ美味しい人がハチミツというラベルを貼っている瓶を取ったら
開けてみたらゴマ油 最悪ですね
我々の問題はそっちであるんです
ラベルを貼ってるんですね
もしどんな瓶もカンムチッタビージャウツという 4つだけだったら
ラベルを貼る必要ないでしょ
どんな命も どんな生命体も見たら
カンマ法則 心の法則 自然の法則
遺伝子の法則で出来上げているんだと
植物もそうでしょうに
植物にも自然が影響を与えているし
植物には逃げることはできませんし
遺伝子で生きているし
いろいろ 植物には業と心は一応仏教はないという風にしているんです
一応あんまり明確にしていないんです
ジャイナ教に怒られますからね
一応仏教の世界ではそれはないことにしているんです
生命になってくると  1と2
カンマとチッタ 業と心
法則があえて入っているんです
だから 物体と生命体の差が
この生命体には法則 2つあり
4つの法則があって 物体の場合は 2つの法則で生きているんですね
私が嫌だからといって太陽の自転は変わらない
そのフレーズを覚えておけば
このポイントはわかります
ということは 太陽が自転するのは自然法則でしょ
他は何もないんです 俺が嫌です
それは じゃあ変わる？変わるわけないでしょうに
だから法則に合わせるしかないでしょ
太陽の自転によってね
四季があったり いろいろありますから
自分がそれに合わせて適応するだけなんですね
人生は そうするとすごい楽なんですね
ですから 自我を捨てて
自我を捨てて法則の働きを認める
ちょっと理解して 法則は何なのかと
今日はそのテーマできませんだからね
まあそれを理解する 無理をして自然に逆らって自己破壊に陥ることを避ける
無理をしない 自然法則に逆らおうと
こんな馬鹿げたことはしない
例えば自分の遺伝子をね
変えてやるぞとかね 遺伝子的に見れば
もう 80歳で死ぬ 俺は嫌だからね
200歳までいる じゃあ遺伝子変えるぞと
変えてみてください 変えられるなら
例えば病弱 遺伝子の問題ある？嫌でしょ
病弱は じゃあ遺伝子変えてみて
変えられるわけないでしょうに
最近研究してますね それもわずかな範囲で
遺伝子のちょっとそれは病気の人の場合はね
ちょっと変えられるのかどうかとかね
それは遺伝子改変して薬を作る場合でも
彼らが法則を守らなくちゃいけない
勝手にね 正しい健康な遺伝子を注射したからといってね
これは入りませんよ だから遺伝子には遺伝子の法則を持ってますから
それを理解して どのように改良した遺伝子を入れるのかと
どのように元の遺伝子にそれを受け取ることさせるのかという
ちょっとしたちょっとしたことではない
かなりの工夫をしなくちゃいけないんです
褒められて舞い上がることもなく
貶されて落ち込んだり怒ったりすることもやめる
自我を捨てたらそんな風になるんです
法則を認める 私 俺 自我というものは存在しない
成り立たない これは 4つの糸で編んだ網ですよ
だから糸の性質 ロープにあります
ロープですからね ロープ
ロープの性質は 4つの糸の
性質を組み合わせてできているんです
それ認めたら 踏み鳴られたからといって別に舞い上がることはできません
自我がないんだからね
貶されたって言うんで
すっと聞いているだけ
流れるままで安穏にいける
その場合は しかし もう一つポイントがある
今流され流れるままできる人生を説明しています
しかし 法則は無常です
ちょっとしたきっかけがあるんですね
法則といっても無常なんで無常でできているんです
だからおかしいんですよ
おかしいというか変ですよ
無常なのにそれがあるんですね
例えば地球は自転するんですね
だからいつでも無常なんです
回るは回るは回るは回るは
自転しながら自転するから公転もする
すごいスピードですよ
ものすごいスピード だから我々宇宙空間でスーッと超高速で動いているんですね
そこは無常ですが 無常が続くんですね
逆に無常だから続くという現象が見えるんですね
はい それからこのもしこの 4つの糸が無常ならば
ずっと変化しているならば
もしかするとそこら辺
何とか何とかすることはできるかな
業の法則と心の法則に注意するべきです
この 4つの糸で業の法則
それから心の法則 それは個人司っている 2つの糸なんですね
いわゆる生命を生命だと名付けるようになる法則 2つですね
だから私は生命だから
私の体重とかね 物質のことを困らなくてもいいんです
酸素がどれぐらいあるかとかね
水がどれぐらい体には心配だわとか
そんなことはどうでもいいんです
しかし この業と心ということは命ですから
そこはちょっと注意した方がいいんですね
心に自分の思考の流れも入っています
そこで心っていうのは
みんなあまり知らないんだけど
思考しているでしょ？考えてるでしょ
ずっと妄想してるでしょ
あれは一つ心の一つの働きなんです
全てじゃなくて 思考によって心の流れが変わります
それを見てみてください
このロープの中で一本が変わるんですよ
思考するたびに 心という糸が変わっちゃうと
ロープ全体も変わるでしょ
例えばロープを作ったんだ
糸 4つもすごいビニール糸みたいなことで
すごい頑丈だったらものすごく強い
そこで一つの一本を外して
あの綿 綿というかね 普通の綿のね
綿の糸を入れちゃうと
あれ 普通の針仕事にしている
使っている糸を使っちゃうと
ロープの力がガクンと 4分 4分の1下がるでしょう
ただ  4つビニールで 3つビニールで
一つはただの cotton の糸だったら
cotton の糸には何の力もなくなっちゃってということになるんです
そういうわけで このロープの 4つで 2つは我々の命を作っているんだからね
そこを自分でなんとか考えれば管理できるんですね
それに合わせて他の法則の働きも変わります
だから 至ってわかりやすいことは
思考 思考は自分で管理すれば
悪い思考をやめて清らかな思考で生きてみる
と見たら 至って簡単 人生全体的に良くなります
だから他の全部変わります
肉体のことであろうか
もう健康のこと 何でも何でも変わります
そこでは神秘的なことは何もないんです
思考さえ正しければ 善思考
清らかな思考持ってみてください
何も無理をする必要はない
人生はものすごくうまく進むんです
思考は貪瞋痴という非論理的な感情で支配されています
問題はそれなんです 思考というのは基本的に貪瞋痴という何の論理も成り立たない感情で感情が支配しているんです
だから私たちは善思考
清らかな思考でいようではいようではないかなと思っても
結構無理なんですね ついつい暗い思考に戻っちゃうんです
例えば次の瞑想したでしょ？これ早く終わっちゃえと
で 気持ちでしょ 静かにいる時はもうもう早くもういいやということになっていると思います
今日はそこを感じる前にストップしたんだけどね
普通は私 それ感じるまで待っているんです
静かに念じてくださいと
そこで私はすごいずるいんだから
私もじっと静かに 私も何時間も静かにいられますからね
思考を止めて 問題ないんだけど
そうするとみんなに思考が生まれてね
イラ立ちが出てきて まあもう始めてください
次の章もう始めて始めろとか
気持ちが生まれてくる
ものすごく感じるんです
それは私は何も文句言わないで
何のことなく次のセクション始まるんです
そこで大体 30秒  40 秒
45 秒ぐらいはみんな静かに念じる
真面目に それからどんどん弱くなって
あれ念じてないんです
それでいろいろ音が来るわ
体を動かすわ いろんなこと聞こえてくるんです
だから それが私が悪口言ってるわけではなくて
そんなもんなんですね
人生っていうのは やっぱり善思考したいんだけど
できない すぐ元に戻る
それの理由は 我々の心が貪
心を貪瞋痴という非論理的な感情が支配しているんです
いわゆる誘拐されているんです
心が 大変なことなんです
だから すべての生命が汚れた思考をしているんです
感情は心の働きの中に竜巻を起こします
そこで感情でが現れると
我々の心に竜巻が起こるんです
皆様にも経験あるでしょ？時々感情が出てくると
怒りやら欲やらね 欲の感情が激しいのは若い子たちの間でね
もうもう右も左も見えなくなっちゃうね
誰かのことを好きになったところで
この人こそやと振られたらガクンと落ち込む
それから何やるかわからない
これ 竜巻起こしてるんですね
大人になってくると まあ結構怒りの感情とかね
結構竜巻を起こしちゃうんですね
憎しみの感情とかね  それで皆さん知って
空気はありがたい 風もありがたい
まあ軽い台風ぐらいだったら別に気にしないでいられる
まあ早く終わりますからね
竜巻はごめんね 何を壊されるかわからない
竜巻が通った道は破壊の道なんです
すべて建物も何でも壊しちゃう
大きな木も根こそぎに取って捨てる
悪いことは家の屋根をこれ持ち上げてどこかに落としちゃうんですね
一回 かなり前ね 台風は竜巻ではなかったんだけどね
強い台風で私は大阪にいたんだけど
まあ駅に行ってみたら
まあ早く東京の行こうかなとかね
あの台風が通ったところで
このどこかの屋根をね
上げて新幹線の線路に落としちゃって
これで 4時間  5時間ぐらい新大阪で待つ羽目になっちゃって
まあこれ待てないんだから
まあ友達に電話してね
今日泊まらせてくれと言ったら
友達が来る時はかわいそうですね
私が新幹線も一応また始めたんです
決めたんだから一晩泊まったんだけど
はい そこで心は別にどうったことない
心はもういじれません
法則ですね でもこの竜巻
これ危険なんです 竜巻が起こして業という法則を呼ぶんです
だから我々は業をあまり実感ない
業を持っていることには実感ないんだけど
まあ実感することはできますよ
これは別なプログラムを組んで皆様に説法しなくちゃいけなくて
説法するだけでも実感できる説法できます
これ瞑想する人の管轄ですけどね
私はとにかく説法だけでこれ体験させようかなと思う時もあります
で 業は実感なくてもいいんです
心の思考が汚れて竜巻を起こしちゃうと
一緒に働く業が派手に汚れます
いわゆる善行が悪業に変わっちゃうんです
そうすると不幸が結果になるんです
ですから 流れるままで生きることは
幸福を目指す人間にとって危険です
だからやめた方がいいんです
しかし 流れるまで生きることは間違っているわけじゃないんです
前説明したでしょ 間違ってるわけじゃないんです
でも 自分のスタンスを考えてほしい
自分が貪瞋痴を持ってるならばやめましょう
流れるまで生きることは
なぜならば 貪瞋痴が思考を汚して竜巻を起こす
起こしちゃったら自分の業も汚して弱くする
そうすると 伊藤の 2つ役に立たなくなっちゃったんです
だったら体力ある限りじゃなんとか生きられますけど
すぐ死んじゃうんです
すぐ不幸になるんです
よくあるでしょ この体壊れちゃうと
我々は病院に連れて行って延命装置つけちゃうんですね
それで生きていられるように見えるだけでしょ
結局は だから この体構成している 4つの法則もほとんどボロボロなんですね
心も業もう使えない 力がない
ただ肉体はまだある 肉体って物質でしょ
それで延命装置入れちゃって
物質をなんとか動かしている
そうすると心も仕方がなくまだまだ繋がっちゃうんだ
これで生きるっていうことにはならないんですね
心が感情を絶って自由になったならば
流れるままにままで安穏に生きるよりほか道はありません
もし心に貪瞋痴の感情がなくなって自由になったならば
その人は何の計画も立てる必要はないんです
そのままいればいいんです
自然の法則に任せて はい
次に行きます 計画する人生
理性が灯火であることを忘れない
計画するときは 我々はみんな忘れることは理性なんですね
まず計画を立てないね
目的がなければ よく言いますよ
この生きることに何の目的もないんだと
わざと言うんです みんなそれでがくんと困るんです
わからなくなっちゃってどうしようかと
それ私の狙いなんです
いい加減にしなさいと
目的ないんだったらね
こんなに真剣で こんなに顔
鬼の顔で生きる必要ないでしょ
すごくリラックスして生きられるのに
だから私は本当に幸福のメッセージをあげているんです
生きることに何の目的もないんですよと
だったら お腹が空いたらご飯を食べればいいし
もう疲れたら寝ればいいし
全然疲れがなかったら夜でも起きていたってもいいし
体が汚れたなと思ったら洗えばいいし
毎日必ず 8時に風呂に入らなくちゃいけませんとか
何か本で効率の本を作ってね
これに縛られて なんで困る？そういう決まりあったら
この人にどこか出かけちゃって
8時半になっちゃって
9時になっちゃうと もうイライラ
毎日 8時にお風呂入るんだけど
私の性格はね どうしようかとか
余計なくだらない悩みでしょうに
必ず朝ごはん食べなくてはいけませんと決めてみてください
どれぐらい苦しみが来るのかと
必ず朝ごはん食べなくちゃいけない
決めたってね 食べられない日は結構出ますよ
だから目的ないんだったら
朝ごはん食べられるならば食べる
今日はもうちょっと朝寝坊したんだから食べませんと気持ちよければ簡単でしょうに
とにかく計画立てるためには目的が必要です
人生を計画して過ごしたいと思うならば
まず目的を設定することです
存在欲が目的を作って
それに向かって生きることを推薦します
そこで目的を作る時は
我々には存在欲があるんです
生きていきたいというね
だから生きること法則だったら
なんで生きていきたいと思うんですかね
ちょっと考えてみてください
地球は自転してほしい
自転してほしい 困ります
ずっと自転するような
なんとかしなくて思う人がいる
これ法則だから放っておけばいいんです
命もそうなんです 法則です
放っておけばいいんです
しかし 放っておけないね
なぜならば存在欲があるんです
だから余計に生きていきたいと思っちゃうんです
いくら思っても法則が壊れると誰だって死にますよ
誰だって死ぬまでは生きられるでしょ
だから別に生きていきたいと思う必要はないんです
とにかく我々作る目的を
目的作りなさいと指令を出しているのは
あの存在欲なんです 知識
周りの影響などで目的が現れます
それで存在欲が生きていきたいだけ言ってくれる
そうすると自分がどうすれば生きていられるのかとイスタリする
そうすると勉強したものからデータ取って
周りからデータを取って
あ 私の目的はこれやと決めるんです
驚くほどのことではありません
人間 いろんな目的を持ってますよ
そんな驚かなくてもいいんです
例えば 日本の14歳の子が何か目的を作る
俺がすごい絶対的な大事な目的を作ったと言われるかというと
インドの14歳の子が別な目的を作っているんです
自分の国の同じ年の子が別の目的を作っているんです
あれは自分が学んだものと周りのいろいろ価値判断から勝手に作るものですよ
どうったことはない 例えば
トランプさんの息子がどんな目的を作るのかと
それ我々聞いて ネットでね
びっくりする 馬鹿はびっくりしますけどね
全然びっくりする必要はないんです
あれ 環境からその目的を作られたんですね
例えば 超一流の音楽家の家族に生まれた子は
私も音楽家になってやると目的を作る
別にどうってことない
それで似たら能力もある
だって4歳から3歳からでもね
いろいろ教えられているんだから
赤ちゃんが吸ってお母さんがララバイを歌っている時でもね
ちゃんとした歌を歌って歌っているんだから
何の間違いもなくプロが歌ってくれているんだから
あの子供はもうどうしても
あの 何て言いますか アブソリュートピッチというね
絶対音感 何でしたっけ
え？絶対音感アブソリュートピッチを持ってるんですね
我々別に驚かなくてもいいんです
そんなのは ああ そうかと
あれは環境のアブソリュートピッチ持ってる人には
結局音楽家になれるし
自分好きなことできる
作曲 作曲することであろうか
演奏することであろうか
歌うことであろうが 別にどうってことない
だからみんないろんな目的
それぞれ作るんですよ
だから人生はどんな目的を作ればいいかと
今まで困ってたでしょ
あれやめてください あんなのはどうでもいいんです
適当でいいんです 教えられたっても
あなたにできるのは あなたの環境とあなたの経験で
あなたの理解能力範囲で目的を作ることだけです
だから人に聞かないで自分で作ってください
例えば私に頼まれたら
私に何か生きる目的を教えてちょうだいと
私は私の能力で 私の知識で目的を作ったって
私は別人だから あの人にそれできるわけないでしょうに
だから大体世の中で目的を作ることに結構困ってるんですね
特に若い子たちがね 全然困らなくていいんです
ふざけていい加減で目的を作ったってもいいんです
ふざけていい加減で目的は本当に作れませんよ
だからお母さん困らなくていいんです
そんなことしたら困りますよとかね
あなたはこういう学問をやらなくちゃいけないとかね
別に言わなければいい学校を選ぶんです
お母さんがお前医者になれ
医者になれとまるっきり言わなかったら
あいつは医者になるんです
だって環境がそうそろってるんだからね
お父さんがお医者さんでかっこよくて
みんなに尊敬されちゃって,それはちらちらと見ると
子供はね 俺も親父に負けたらあかんとかね
お母さんがあなたもお父さんと同じこと言われた途端
やるもんかと 人の真似どうちゃうんです
お父さんに言われたら絶対嫌やと思うんですね
お母さんには絶対嫌と言えませんだから洗脳されてるんだからね
心の中でやるもんかと決めてるんです
だからそんな戦いは苦しいでしょうに
ですから 大体放っておけば
みんななんかふざけているように見えるんだけど
それぞれの目的を作るんですね
そこで目的を作らせることできないで困っている人々もいます
それはどういうことかというと
親の育ちが悪いんですね
親がペットを飼っているんです
ペットの場合は何でもしてあげるでしょ
ペットがカーペットの絨毯の上でゲロを出しちゃっても困りませんね
何のことなくそこを綺麗にしてあげる
ペットはもうそんなままいればいいんです
そのように自分の子供を育てるんです
だから人間でなくなっちゃうんです
犬になるんです だから犬が餌くれるまで待っている
犬がもう餌がなかったら
もう可愛くておっぱふったり
もういろいろ顔に口をつけたり
いろんなことをする それで
お前お腹がすいたのって帰ってる人が餌あげたりする
だから 両親が自分の子供を犬にしちゃうんだから
そういう人々は目的は作れなくなっちゃうんです
ただいればいいやと 時々大学まで行くんだけど
大学卒業してから仕事に行かない
家に泊まる あの力がないんです
わからない なんで会社に行って
毎日朝から朝早く行って
遅くまで遅くなって帰って
これって一生やらなくちゃあかんよとかね
何のためにだと 部屋で漫画読んでたら楽ちんなのにと
そう思っちゃうんです
だからまあ そこは親が責任持ってください
ああいうのは一応なかなか治りませんよ
長い間人格奪われて ロボットにされて
脳を壊されてるんです
ですから 私は今言っているのは
計画を立てて生きていければ
どうったことはない 頑張ってくださいなんですね
そんなに大したことはないんだ
普通だと しかし 目的を作らなくちゃいけない
で なんか計画なりとかね
目的は困ります 困らなくていい
あんた勝手になんか目的作ってください
気楽に 感情が優先になると考えられる目的はろくなものではありません
しかし 感情で 例えば若い子二人がいてね
お互い友達なんですけど
こいつに勝ちたいと思っちゃうんですね
こいつより優れたなんとか目的しなくちゃって
そこは感情なんです そうすると
なんか変な目的作っちゃう
それがろくな目的じゃない
時々ろくでもない目的を作っている若者がいるんですね
私は長いとんているんだから
私の若者の場合はね 年齢が結構幅があるんです
で  30歳で私から見れば若者なんですね
いるでしょ 世の中であれやりたい
これやりたいとかね ろくなものじゃないんですね
だから大人が いい加減にしなさいよと
もっと真面目に生きてみたらどうですか？と
ぐちゃぐちゃ言わなくちゃいけない
なんであんなどうでもいい目的作って
もうろくでもない人間になってしまうのかというと
この場合は感情に支配されて目的を作っているのです
感情が危険で だから私は理性が楽しみです
理性で導いてもらわないと
それで理性を使用すると実現できるか
役に立つか 苦労して頑張る価値があるか否かなどを考察する
もし目的を作る時は もうちょびっと理性を使ってみると
その人が私の目的は現実的ですかね
役に立つ これで苦労して頑張る価値があると自分に問いてみる
それだったら立派な目的でしょ
自分だけのことではなく
周りの親しい人々の幸福も考えられる
理性ちょっと高くなってくると
私だけ幸せになったらこれはダメです
私の家族やらお母さんやらおじいさんやら友達やら
みんな幸せになる人間にならなくちゃいけないと
もうちょっと上を目指すんですね
上を目指すんですね 理性がさらに発達している人なら
人類 他の生命に役に立つことを目的にします
それで面白いこと 人類の役に立つことを考えて計画を立てると
大げさじゃないんです
みんな応援するんです
でっかい目的かもよ ある若い子がでっかい目的を作る
理性 その目的が達成したら人類の役に立つ
そうするとみんな協力する
親だけじゃないんです
友達だけじゃないんです
話聞く 聞く人 協力する
だから全然大丈夫 理性さえあれば
法則を犯してはならないと知っている人なら
目的に達することがほとんどかないんです
自我張って性格に逆らう
それやめたら誰だって目的は達します
全然大丈夫です 法則は逆らえないんです
ですから そこだけ理解して
目的を作って頑張ってみる
それで法則に許される範囲で頑張っているんです
例えば 激しく流れる川で自分がボートを漕いでいる
エンジンではなくて 手で
法則に逆らってできる？できない
ちゃんと法則にも合わせてボートを漕いで
自分が達したい 行きたいところに行ける
無理で無理ということはないんです
流れを見て ここの流れすごい激しい
だからこちらにボートが行っちゃうと流されますからね
あるいは覆ったりするかも
だからそこら辺で ここをこちねこちねこちんと
ちょっとちょっと別なところに持っていって
そこに行っちゃうと石があります
あ これにぶつかっちゃったらアウト
だから綺麗に石にぶつからないように
またまともとかに調整するんですね
そういう調整しながら進むんです
理性あるから法則に逆らってない
向こうの岸に行きますから
一番早いのは一直線にボートを漕いだ方が一番早いといって
バカですね 川が激しいんだったら
一直線では行けませんね
それでも狙ったところに行きたければ
ここから一直線ではなくて
もっと上の方から始まる
上の方から川に入って漕いでいると
川に流される部分に流されて
ちょうどいいところにぴちっとつけるんです
目的を達成する方法っていうのはそういうことなんです
法則って川にどこから入るのかと
はい それからお釈迦様が
この問題についてどのように語ったのかと
完全に幸福に達する 実現することが確実に成功する企画書
仏教にあるんです 今日は中身には入らないと思います
まず 様々な目的について学んでみましょう
時代 流行 文化 家族などの環境
年齢 性別などによって目的が変わるのに
大げさに考える必要はありません
そこでリラックスしましょう
18歳の女の人が作る目的と 18歳の男が作る目的は違いますから
これなんで認めない？ 18歳の女の子と35歳の女性が作る目的はまた違うんです
これを覚えておきましょう
ということは 我々は年取るとともに目的が変わるんですね
例えば 私が30代で持っていた目的は
今はひとかけらもないんです
今別な目的 今70歳だから
70代だから 歳ではなくて
今別な目的 まあじゃあ私はこの目的に縛る？縛る
縛りません また年取ると
またこれはどのように変わるかよくわからない
だからそんな目的っていうことは
仏教は あ そうということで終わっちゃうんです
例えば 私に向かってね
私は本当にエンジニアになろうと思ってるんですねと
ああ そう じゃあ頑張って
すごいですね あなたはねとかないんです
素晴らしいですよとかね
どうでもいいんで ダメなの
なぜならば ある日 エンジニアになりたいと頑張っているんだと言った子が
1年経ってから あれやめちゃってね
音楽家になろうかなと今思ってるんだよと言ったら
どうする？もし私がエンジニアになること素晴らしいです
あなたこれずっと頑張ってくださいと
これもう反抗してもう決めてあげちゃうと
あの子はもう 1年経ってから私の顔を見ない
もう顔を合わせないでしょ
でも私のあのいい加減な返事でしたら
また来て もうやめちゃった
もう音楽家になると思ってる
あ そう じゃあ頑張ったら
それもそう 冷静で 皆さんはそうなってください
だって皆様本人もそうでしょう
目的は変わるわ 変わるわ
変わるわ それが自然です
全て無常だから 目的だけ固定するはずがないでしょうに
二十歳頃の女の子が結婚したい
結婚したいと思っているかも
じゃあ頑張れば そういう風に言った人は何人かいたんだからね
頑張るわ あの子に 2人ぐらいに言ったんだよね
あのね 結婚して必死になる
ならない なるなよと あんたすごい怖くなっちゃいますよと
だから男は逃げるは逃げるはもう後ろを向くことなく逃げるんだよと
だってあなた友達になったらあんたにすぐ捕まえますからね
だからそこをやめて 普通に可愛くて
気が気が利く 優しい女の子になりなさい
可愛いという女の子になって
誰かバカがあなたを買いますよと
勝手に言って気に入ったと
それは法則を達する方法なんです
目的に達する方法なんです
そんなんと自分で頑張らないと人を見つからないよと言ったら
まあ見つからなかったらそのままでいいんじゃない？別に女っていうのは必ず結婚するべき誰だみたいですかね
結婚できなかったら独身でどう生きるのかと新しい目的を作ればいい話でしょ
それに幸福は逃げないでしょ
結婚が幸福だと思った人が結婚できなかったら不幸
そこら辺考えてください
目的は誰であれ どんな人間も目的は作るは作るは作るは
それも流れて無常で流れて流れて変わっていく
ブッダの示すところは
あなたはどのように目的に達するまで進めるかということです
仏教側の関心は この連中の目的に
この連中は目的に達するのかと
目的に達することできなくなって失敗しちゃって
不幸に陥ることだけは良くない
だから面白い 仏教は目的に対して何も言いません
人が個人で勝手で目的を作ってもいいんです
どんな目的を作っても
仏教側が目的に達するか否かを心配する
省略するならば 人の性格
人格が決め手です ブッダの教えをすべて省略してみると
目的に達するの場合は性格が決め手です
すべて性格 自分の生き方
自分の人格が決定権を持ってるんです
人格がだらしないとだったら
目的に誰も達しません
人格が悪い 恐ろしい 目的に達しません
目的は何でもいいんです
生きる闘いに挑む前に生き方
この生き方と専門的に道徳と言うんですね
私は道徳という単語はあまり使いたくない
何か道徳というと 何か嫌な宗教っぽいものだと思いますけど
道徳とは生き方なんです
生き方は嫌やと言える
だって生き方は正しい生き方をしなくちゃあかんでしょうに
正しい生き方に道徳と言うんです
別にこれは誰かさんが語る必要はないんです
で 生き方を改善しなくてはならないんです
我々は生きる闘いに挑むならば
生き方を改善しましょう
目的に達するために教えている教典だけ紹介します
このマンガリスッタという教典があります
教会で出している 日常読数なんとかってテキストにあったような気がします
あったっけ  入ってますね
吉祥寺ですね  吉祥寺入ってます
それからパラバーをすったという
それは入っていないと思いますけど
スッタニパータというブッダの言葉という中村先生が訳した本がありましてね
そちらにはありますね
それからシガーレ経典ですね
私も本も出してますね
それでパッタカムスッタって
アングッテルニカチャットカニパーテの 7番目の7の2番目の経典ですね
で それは説法したことはないんですけどね
日本訳はあるでしょう
あるとは思いますけどね
それからディークジャーヌスッタっていうよね
これはアングッテルニカあったか
8のセクションで 6の6番の 1.4 経典なんですね
でまあそこそんな程度でしか言えません
時間的にあまり時間がないんです
こんな漫画ですって広げちゃうと
もう 2時間半  3時間説法しなくちゃあかんです
だからブッダが短く語っても
全体的にすべて語るんです
だから皆様 それを全部読まなくてもいいんです
あの吉祥経典だけ読んでみて
あれは幸福になる道ない
お釈迦様は目的特別に教えてないんです
例えば まずアセーナチバーラーナ
無知な人を仲間にするなよと
パンディターマンディセーナ
知恵のある理性の頭のいい人々と付き合ってみてください
目的だけ書いてないでしょ
書いてない これやれば成功します
例えば商売したいと もう無駄な無駄使いばっかりする
お金が入ったら使う 借金までしてゲームやる
バカが友達だったら この人に商売できる？だからちゃんと商売できる先輩と仲良くしてみると
自分にも道が見えてくる
それから 3番目のこのプージャプージャにはというのも
名声のある人 尊敬に値するべき人々をちゃんと尊敬しなさいと
仕事を関わする相手も
尊敬に値する人だったらちゃんと挨拶して尊敬する
そうすると いつでもこの人を社会が応援する
それからパティループです
場所を適した場所に引っ越ししなさいと
音楽になりたいと思ったら
どこかですごい もう日本の田舎に住んでいる
だって無理でしょう 買い物に行くことにしたっても
車で 45 分 1時間かかると
それだったら東京に来るか
ちっちゃなボロアパートでもここら辺ね
上野のところら辺でね
住むとかね あるいはフランスに行くとかね
ドイツに行くとか なんとか場所を変えた方がいいんじゃない？それで
お釈迦様がその目的ではなくて
目的は勝手に自分勝手で作って
達するためにこの条件を守る
32 の項目があります
マンガリスってればパラダイスったっていうのは
これだけやめなさいという
この反対の経典なんです
いわゆる堕落の経典 堕落の道を教えて
いわゆる目的は潰れる方法
マンガラっていうのは
吉祥っていうのは目的が目的に達する方法
だから両方対立的に教えてますよ
これ学んだら これ以上この世の中でどこにもないんで
こんな地位 それでシガーラ経典っていうのは
最近のお釈迦様の教えっていうふうな
なんとかタイトルタイトル忘れちゃったんだけど
まあ知ってる人教えてください
ちょっと本も私も頼まれて出したんですね
そちらで若い子にどのように
成功して生きるのかという
このプログラムをしっかりと教えているんです
その場合の目的は こんな目的を作ってくださいはないんです
それは人権侵害なんです
音楽家になりたい人に百姓さんになりなさいというのは人権侵害でしょ
それはお釈迦様はしません
百姓さんになろうか 商人になろうか
音楽家になろうか あの公務員になろうか
それは関係ない このようにやってくださいと目的に達しようと
性格を改良する方法と正しい生き方が具体的に語られています
その経典文の中で この世で幸福に生きることと
死後幸福になる道を説かれています
それでお釈迦様が人間の目的にちょっとあの加えてあげるんです
人間には大した目的作れないんですね
そのどんな目的を作っても
人間の狙いはこの世で幸福に生きてみたいと
それにお釈迦様はこの世だけではなくて
あの世もつなげましょうよと
一本に それだけ無理につなげてあげるんです
だから この経典の中で
この世で幸福になることだけではなくて
死後も幸福になることもつなげているんです
そこを気をつけてください
いろいろ人 いろんな開発
本を書いている人々のプログラムと違うところはそこなんです
もっとお釈迦様は真面目なんです
あのベストセラーを作って金を狙うは狙いことはないんです
ブッダの指導を実践するならば
人の正しい目的は何であろうとも現実することができます
私は本当に今 100%できます
それぐらいすごいんです
ただ ブッダに教えた通りにやってみてください
正しい目的 例えば人類を破壊したいんだと
なぜ正しい目的で金正恩にも目的あるんですけどね
私たちから正直な話は
金正恩の目的の目的に達しますようにじゃなくて
あいつは早く死にますように
正直なところ 誰かあいつを蹴っ飛ばしてやってくれないのかと
誰かが逮捕して あいつをね
終身刑にしてくれないのかとかね
だから人類は応援しませんよ
あんな目的は 例えばインドで死んだガンジーさん
死んですごい日にち 年月経ってますけど
いまだに尊敬している
世界でインド人は神様だと勘違いしている
それぐらい死んでも ガンジーさんの目的はインドを独立することだけだったけど
だから良い目的だったら
まあなんのことなく完成する
ガンジーさんもブッダのことをブッダの方法を学んだならば
あれを起こしてトラブル一つも起こさないんです
ガンジーさんの人生を読んでみると
うーん このおじいさんもね
悪くはないんだけど いいとも言えないという状態なんです
はい これで話が終わって次に行きます
超越した目的 この様々な妄想の目的の中で
誰にだって思うべき超越した目的があるんです
1個あるんです お釈迦様のこの世の幸せ
人間が考えている お釈迦様
教えてくださいったら
お釈迦様が じゃあ君の目的にこれもつけましょう言って
目的に死後の幸福をつけてあげる
つけてあげて こういう風に頑張ってください
だから個人が考えた目的があるでしょ
お釈迦様はその上に死後の目的
幸福もつけておく それで説法する
個人の目的がそれぞれバラバラだからね
お釈迦様が乗せるものはみんなと同じ
それ以上もう一つ乗せるんです
究極での目的 すべて超越した目的
存在を脱出すること自体が優れた目的です
存在そのものを脱出しましょうと
このグニャグニャグニャグニャ変化するロープでいることがもう意味がないんだと
ロープの 4つの糸もずっと無常で変化するんです
だからロープの性質は変わるわ
変わるわ 変わるわ まあ面倒くさい
だったら捨てましょうと
そんなのはと 計画的に実行する
それでチョイスした目的の場合も
流されたままではダメなの
計画を立てなくちゃいけないんですね
はい それにはこんなものになります
まず智慧で始まるんです
ブッダの ブッダが作った目的あります
我々もあんたもこの目的を作ってくださいと
我々チョイスする 存在
それだったらまず智慧から始まります
一番目の智慧は 一切の現象は無常ですということ
すごい科学的でしょ？宇宙の法則
全部まとめて何見ても無常です
変化しているんです だから自分も宇宙の一部でしょ？自分も無常で
自分ということは成り立たないとわかるんです
計画する人生で高度な目的に達しても
それは無常 音楽家になっても無常
演奏できない時あります
医者になっても無常 仕事を辞めなくちゃいけない時が来ます
金儲けでも無常 金がなくなるか
自分が死ぬかどちらかになるんです
家を作っても 作ったその日から家がボロボロに古くなっていくんです
存在欲があるから計画を立てたり
実行したり 成功したり失敗したりします
存在欲は生きていきたいというね
だから計画立てるは立てるは
朝の計画と午後の計画は違うわ
朝の目的とね 午後の目的が違うわ
朝 朝の目的も午後の目的も同じであっても
朝の計画と午後の計画は変わるわ
はちゃめちゃですよ 人間が
そこで成功する場合もあるし
失敗する場合もある この道は楽ではありませんが
存在欲のせいでやめられない
だから我々は計画的に生きているでしょ
結構大変ですよ 計画的に生きることは本当に苦しいんです
でもやめられますかね？やめられませんね
くだらない計画かもしれませんよ
だらしない計画かもしれませんよ
自分が作った計画だからね
これはやめられないんです
あるいは失敗する計画がわかってますけど
やめられないんです なんでかというと
存在欲があるからなんです
だから人間っていうのは
一度失敗したら何度でも失敗するんです
だって お前とやり方は同じだ
いつでも そういうのまたやるんです
人は自己観察して計画を立てたくなる衝動を発見します
ですから 今チョイスレベルでしょ
語っているのは まず なんで私が目的を作りたいんですかね？なんで計画を立てたいんですかねとか
それで観察すると 自己観察すると
生きていきたいと あの衝動が見えてくるんです
私は死にたくない 生きていきたい
あの感情を発見しましょう
それは苦の回転であると発見
次に生きてきたら だから私は苦しんでいるんだと
死にたくないと馬鹿が思っているんだから
当然死ぬのに死なないようにハチャメチャ苦労しているんだと
だから 存在欲から出てくるのは苦しみであると
放っておけば何もないんだとわかるんです
だったらどうする？存在欲を断つ
これ 智慧がなければできません
存在とは 4つの法則のが編み込んだロープです
この法則が変わる変わる変わる変わる
いい例えが出てこないんですよ
例えば  4つの滝が一箇所で一緒になる
なったら大きい滝になるだけなんです
一個一個の滝も無常で流れるでしょうし
4つになったからといって止まるわけじゃないんです
そもそも滝は滝なんです
流れる 無常です それで私たちはそれを知って
余計にこの 4つの糸が編んだところで
編んだではなくて 自然に一緒になっているだけですから
存在欲という二次元的なものが現れるのです
セカンダリーエフェクトという
もともとないんですけど
組み合わせたら何か変なものは現れてくる
例えば熱で空気があの温度の差が現れると
空気層にね 光が屈折する
それで蜃気楼に見える
本気で見えますよ ちゃんと目に映ります
でも実際はそれはないんだけどね
だからいくつかの原因が揃っちゃうと
何か変なものが現れるっていうことはよくあること
そこで このカマチッタとビジュとウドと 4つの法則か組み合わせるところで
存在欲という蜃気楼が現れたんですね
そこをなくしちゃう 知恵で発見したらなくします
法則にアクセスできます
仏教的に物事を見ると
改良できるところもあります
あの科学者もやってます
科学者は物質にアクセスしているんです
物質は自然法則で動いています
物理法則で動いてます
しかし 科学者がこれをちょっといじるんです
車作るんです 弾道ミサイル作るんです
原子爆弾を作るんです
皆様 科学者がありがたいと思ってるでしょ
あの連中のほんのわずかですよ
ありがたいのは みんなもうだらしない連中なんです
だって大量破壊兵器作ったりするのは科学の科学者の半分以上です
だから褒め立てるなら白井さんを褒め立ててください
素晴らしい 尊い仕事やと
科学者は人類の財産を大量に食ってしまって
ものすごい破壊兵器ばっかり作ってるんです
しかし そんなことどうでもいいんだけど
この連中は物理法則にアクセスしています
自然界にウランあっても
ウランは純粋にないんです
自然界のウランは何の悪い影響も与えません
それを取り出して 法則的にウランをきれいにして
そうすると恐ろしいものになる
それまたあらゆるからくりをして爆弾にするまでする
だから我々は空は飛びません
空を飛ぶためにはすごい軽いものでなければ
綿みたいなね 軽いものでなければ空は飛べません
しかし ものすごい重いジャンボジェット機が
我々は荷物まで入れて飛んでおりますね
あれは自然ごとに逆らっているわけじゃないんです
自然法則を丸ごと使っているんです
使ってちょっとアクセスしているんです
だから飛行機が空気の上に乗っているんです
重い空気 飛行機が しかし
空気の上に乗せませんだから自分で台風を引き起こしているんですね
飛行機が 台風を引き起こして浮いているんです
しかし 浮いていくことはできませんだから
それに適したすごいスピードを持たなくちゃいけない
本当は実際 飛行機がスーッと落ちているんです
落ちることをコントロールすると飛ばしているんです
そういうわけで 科学者さえ科学者は自然物質にアクセスできている
我々は じゃあ心の奥深いにアクセス必要ではないかと
アクセスできます やり方は同じ
まず観察する 科学者も同じでしょ
物質のありさまを観察する
組み合わせたらどうなるのかと観察する
鉄はなぜなぜ錆びるのかと観察する
そうすると 錆びない鉄を欲しいやと思う
それだったら錆びる原因を取り除く
それでステンレススチールが現れてくる
錆びない 法則に逆らっている？逆らっていない
逆らっているように見えるだけ
だから我々は物質はどうったことないんだから
命じゃないんだから 心にアクセスしてみます
心のアクセスは自己観察から始まるんです
心とは自分なので問題なく改良ができます
だから心って自分ですから
問題なく改良できます
一切は無常であると発見すると
存在欲が断たれます だから本当に観察して一切は無常ということだけ発見してください
存在 存在欲が消えます
計画をする必要が消えます
それから無常だったら
なんで計画する？いらない
究極の安穏に達します
その人は究極の安穏に達します
解脱は計画する人の管轄です
そこで仏教は究極の安穏には解脱
涅槃といろいろ単語を使っています
あの単語の意味はわかりませんね
わからない単語を使っています
だってわからないんだからね
しかし 科学的に立証できる概念なんです
こういうものだったら
こういうのがなくなったらなる状態です
存在欲があるから この世の中がありますね
存在がなくなったら現れる状態を涅槃というんです
はい これで話は終了です
そういうわけで 結論にまた戻る必要ありますか？結論は
人生は一日に限るんだと
だから我々は長期計画どうでもいいんだから
一日の計画で生きてみましょう
それに一日の計画では
あの世の幸福も出てきます
例えば 今日だけの命だったら
私は前の命を殺す 前の生命を殺すのは
私は長生きしたいからでしょ
私は今日死ぬかもしれませんと思ったら
この人は嫌な人かもしれませんね
別に殺す必要はないんです
余計なことを そういうことで
1 日の計画で生きている人は
この世の幸福 あの世の幸福
両方得られます  1 日だと 1 日だと
毎日そこで真面目に 1 日限った生き方をすると無常見えてきます
そうすると貪欲が消えちゃう
そこで解脱に達しています
で お釈迦様が 1 日講義するという経典で
この解脱に達した人の生き方を教えているんです
解脱者は何の計画もなく 1 日だけで生きているんです
はい 話は以上です  2点お聞きしたいことがあるんですけれども
サーリプッタイマシメのお経の中で
パーリ語の単語でわからないのもあるんですけど
パマッタとクッシータって同じなまけだと思うんですけど
こちらの単語の違いを知りたいんですけれど
もう一度言ってください
単語  はい パーリ語の  パマッて
パマッタ パマッタ パマッタとクッシータ
クッシータ  クッシータ
はいはい  同じ怠けっていう意味だと思うんですけど
その違いがあれば教えていただけますか？ 似てるんだけど
レベルの違いなんですね
クッシータっていうのは
よく怠けなんですね 我々知ってる範囲の怠け
いわゆるやるべきことを後回しにする
これはすごいレベル高く見ると
パマッタ いわゆる放逸
その場合は瞬間瞬間で生きるべきなのに
我々は放逸して過去を考えたり
未来を考えたりして生きている
過去を考えたり 未来を考えたりして生きる人はパマッタなんですね
放逸的な生き方 クッシータっていうのは
勉強を後回しにするとかね
まあそういう感じで やるべきことを具体的にやるべきことをやめちゃう
その人も勉強を後回しにするのは
もうまあ将来のことを何か考えているでしょうね
とにかく怠け者なんですね
その程度のレベルの差なんですね
はい 次のお質問  もう一つはい
えっと カッサパ長老のお経って
よく法要でお話唱えられるお経で
マハーカッサパテーラボッジャンガはい
あの こちらでお釈迦様がカッサパ尊者をお迎えに来て
七覚支を説かれたので
そこでカッサパ長老が病が回復したというお経なんですけれども
そちらのお経を我々が唱える中で
我々がその病や悩み等を抱えている時に
そのお経を唱えることで何か功徳のようなものが得られるものがありますか？ お経の中で仏説のお経を読んだら
何度経典があるとも功徳なんですね
心は清らかになる それは問題ない
仏説でない経典もありますね
人が書いたものは あんなものはどうでもいいです
くだらない それだから漫画読んでください
ブッダのお経ってブッダに説かれたものは何であろうともすごい功徳になります
どうしても心には影響を与えます
心は改良します 改善します
だからカッサパボッジャンガってスッタも同じで
七覚支解脱に解脱を完成するために必要な条件七つが説かれているんですよ
だからそれ我々読んでみたって
そういう条件なのかとわかると
自分の修行がうまくいくんです
読んだだけでも 私も読むとすごい気持ちよくなるんです
我々は節を入れてね サティサンボッジャンガオカッセペ マヤサンマダッカートーバーヴィトーバフリーカトーアヴィンニャーエサンブーダーエニッバーナーエサンワッテティと
いうふうに読むんですね
そうすると サティっていうのは気づきですね
これ一つの覚支であると
お釈迦様が発見しましたと
アヴィンニャーエ 超越した智慧に達します
サンボーダーエ 解脱に達します
ニッバーナエ 涅槃に達しますよと
で 読むとすごい心が落ち着きますよ
だから そこをよく理解できる人の病気だったらもう治ります
はい 読んでみてください
この通りになります  ありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
計画するよりも流されるより
しかし 行動の結果というのは
4本の糸あるいは人格によって規定されるというようなお話を伺いました
そうしますと いわゆる怠け者はです
怠け者はですね どうやって不放逸ではなく
何をもとに怠けから脱することができるんでしょうか
あの怠けという単語っていうのは
この計画から現れるんですね
全て相対的だからね 全てのものはね
例えば晩御飯作るという計画が現れる
それも相対的ですよ 相対的では晩御飯作らなくちゃいけないという計画が現れたところで
まあ嫌ですね これはまあちょっとという風で後回しにしちゃうと
そこが怠けで だから毎日我々は怠けと戦わなくちゃいけない
だっていつでも何か計画がないと動かないでしょ？だから喉が渇いたら水が飲みたいという目的が現れると
そうすると実行しなくちゃいけないね
蛇口まで行って ガラスを取って
蛇口を開けて 水を入れて閉めてもう飲むと
すごいプログラムでしょうに
だからそこでも蛇口まで行きたくないという怠けが出てくる
ガラスを探せば面倒くさいと怠けが出てくるということが現れる
そうすると家の誰かに呼ぶ
何々あのねとかね 怠け者とか呼ぶと誰も家にいない
すると腹が立ったりする
なんでこいつはもう勝手に家出出ているんでしょうかとかね
だからそこに働いているのは怠けなんですね
不放逸 不放逸っていうのはすごい高度なことで
この智慧が現れるために
瞬間瞬間のことを観察しなくちゃいけない
あるいは生きるということは
今の瞬間の勝負なんです
だから今の瞬間に精一杯で勝負して生きることが不放逸ない
あ 不放逸ですね 今の瞬間で料理しながら明日のことを考える
料理しながら旦那の悪口を考えると場合は放逸ですね
苦しむんですね 料理は怠けてないんです
ちゃんと料理作ってるんです
しっかりと美味しいものを
しかし いくらが私は手を込んだ料理を作ったって
一度炊いてもね 美味しいとかね
感謝するとか認めるとかの得が全然ないんだから
食ってみるだけやからとかね
言って考えると これは放逸
怠けではないんですね
頑張ってます 怠けじゃないんです
しかし その女性が悩み苦しみを受けるんです
幸福がなくなるんです
そこで不放逸っていうのは料理に集中する
切る 切る 切る切ると取る
入れる 洗う パイパン取る
置く ガスコンロの場合はつける
油取って入れる あげるとかね
そのその瞬間の世界に生きている
それは不放逸なんですね
これは前に説明しましたから
すごいはっきりと このレベルの差ですかね
俗世間的ですね 怠けは
放逸は仏教が見ている智慧の世界で見た欠点なんですね
それで答えられたかどうか自信の私もないんだけどね
俗世間的な怠けをはい
解決と言ったら変ですけど
とにかく何かやらなきゃいけないことがある
で それはどうしてもできない
嫌なことはやりたくない
やるべきだとはわかっているけど
やりたくない うん そういう場合
何か前へと進めるような知恵というのは何かありますでしょうか
簡単です やりたいことはさっさとやっちゃった方がいいでしょ
やりたくないものを先にやっちゃえば
やりたいものを味わって楽しむ
はい それだけです それ以外の九州を考えないでください
気楽にできます  はい 他の方どなたかいらっしゃいましたら挙手していただければ
はい  どうもありがとうございました
あの ちょっと前から今度伺いたいと思っていた質問なので
今回の話と関係ないことかもしれないですけれども
あの 不殺生っていうことに関して
仏教の方はゴキブリとか蚊とかも殺さないのでしょうか？っていうことと
あと自分がチベットからインドに亡命した子たちの里子に関わっていた里子に関わっていたというか
里子の教育支援に関わっていた経緯から
ダライラマがこう中国との戦争をしないで国を出るという形で占領された結果
起きたことなどに関して
そしてそのダライラマが平和活動を講演しているけれども
いまだにチベットの独立ができていないというような現状などをから考えた時に
その軍隊というものをどう考えるべきなのかということについて
ちょっと迷っちゃうというか
指針をもらいたいということがありまして
その長老のご意見を教えていただきたいと思っています
あの 1 番目の質問は考えるのは構わないんだけど
2 番目の質問はただ自分自身で悩む結果だけになりますけどね
一応お答えいたします
1 番目の質問だから 仏教とはゴキブリも蚊も殺さないのか
これはよくわかりませんね
個人個人の問題だからね
仏教の考えは不殺生なんです
個人でやるかやらないかって
これを個人責任で殺生したら
それは悪行為で不善になるし
不殺生戒を守ればすごい善行為になりますし
自分が幸福になります
それは確かなんですね
だから 戒律を守る人はゴキブリは殺せませんよ
蚊も殺せません だからといってゴキブリは痛い放題とか
蚊蚊が入りたい放題 刺したい放題ではないんです
人間には自分を守る能力がありますから
私たちは家を綺麗にして蚊取り線香を立てたり
あるいは家を全体的にネットを張ってね
入らないようにしたりとか
自分を守ることは正しいんですね
自分の命さえ守らないバカはね
何ができるんですかね
だから自分の命を守るんであって
蚊を恨んでるわけじゃないんです
ゴキブリを恨んでるわけじゃないんですね
だから正しく戒律を守る人はゴキブリ見ても生命だと
そいつはその世界で幸せでいればいいし
でも家の中から出て行った方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
ということで 自分の身を自分も身を守る
身を守るために殺生しない手段をとる
それは仏教的な正しい生き方になるんですね
例えば何か体を塗ったりもするでしょ
虫除けとかね あれは別にとは思いますよ
私は虫よけに使うのはなんとか植物の油ですね
自分たちの国ではいくらでもありますけどね
で こちらが溶かしたものじゃなくて
ものすごいごっついコンセントレイトしたものありますけどね
あれはほんのちょっと純粋なものね
ほんのちょっとどこかに入っちゃうと
体に結構かぶっちゃいますね
だからもう寄ってこないです
それからあの油は体にはいいんです
塗って体に悪影響もない
だから自然の液体でしょ
あれはレモングラスというレモングラスのエキスですよ
そういうふうに人間も人間なりに身を守る
工夫する 蚊は蚊なりに自分の身を守り
工夫する そんな世界ですからね
あまり関わらない方がよろしいと思います
はい 次にダライラマの問題に入ります
あのダライラマ１４世は語ってるんだけどね
まあどこかで完全ではないっていうことはありますよ
だから完璧にブッダの道を実践したならば
そういう問題は起きません
皆様はどう思ったっても
最初からチベットは中国と組んだ方が良かったと思いますね
だって皇帝にも教えたのはダライラマたちでしょうに
だから自分たちが独立した国になろうというところで
独立した国になっているのは
中国は凶暴な国だから気に入らん
漢民族だからね だからそれを理解すれば
あの連中はこういう性格だから仲良くするしか道がないんだ
中国っていうのは 友達になったら何でもしてくれるんですよ
もうちょっと対立的になっちゃうと
もう会うとどうするかわからない
そういうことをしちゃうんだよ
だからそこを理解すれば
中国系の人々というのは友達にしたらすごい味方になるんです
だからチベットっていうのは文化はつながっているし
行ったり来たり十分同じ国境はなかったんだから
昔はね だからダライラマさんたちがね
あまり自分が政治家になる格取らないで
今ダライラマさんが政治家ではなくて
私はフーアーユー？という質問をすると
アイムジャストブリッスマンって言うんですね
あのスタンスは昔も守っていたならばね
私 ある日こう言うんですね
世間は私は政治家だと言ってますよと
ピープルシンクアイムポリティシャンイフアイムポリティシャン
アイムポリティシャンオブザワールドという答えを出しちゃったんですね
世界は私は政治家だと思っているんだと
もし私が政治家であるならば
私は世界最低の政治家ですよと
だって国民守ってないんだからね
だからその人は素晴らしいんだけどね
後からわかっても遅いでしょう
だから中国政府はチベットを自分の管轄下に入れたいと思ったところで
どうぞどうぞと言って一緒になった方が
チベット文化は消えませんよ
だって中国人が共産主義だからって中国人の文化消えてないでしょうに
中国人の仏教はあるし
トレもあるし 一時的にマオゼ東の時はね
ダメージ受けたんだけど
また復活しましたから
そう そんなに問題じゃないんですね
それから今更考えれば
チベット人が中国になったら良かったんじゃない？まあ世界一金持ちだからね
今世界は日本も待ってます
中国の観光客が来るまで
だって我々秋葉原に行ったらね
もうせいぜい 2万円の買い物するんだけど
隣に並んでいる中国の女の子は 200万円の買い物するんだから
だから中国チベット人が仏教を守って
すごく豊かになれたんじゃないかなと
だからそこら辺でね 自分の立場を固持したところでちょっと失敗なんですね
だから形どうであろうとも自我張ってはならない
我々の文化を守ってやるぞと思ったってのも
結局は自我なんです この世の中は無常だから
何も守れません だから
ああそうですか じゃあどうぞと一言言えばよかったのにね
私はこのチベットが中国がチベット侵略した時点でもその考えでいたんです
しかし 私だけその意見でみんな猛反対するんだから
中国反対とかね チベットの解放をやるとかね
私は一人で無理するなよと当時でも思っていたね
だから中国政府は未だにダライラマさんを認めないというね
しかし 仏教を認めないではないんです
そういうことでね まあこんなこと我々考えたってもね
何の結果もないでしょうね
その程度にしてください
はい  今日もありがとうございました
先ほどキリスト教のお話が出てきたんですけれども
キリスト教の愛と仏教の慈悲ってどういうふうに違かったか
自分なりには仏教の慈悲っていうのは
一致して天国に向かっている気持ちだと思うんですけど
キリスト教は人間だけが愛の対象だと思うんですけれども
そういう定義でよろしいでしょうか
まあ悪くないと思いますが
キリスト教っていうのは毎日改良する宗教だから
世界が批判すると即改良するんですよ
だからキリスト教には我々仏教徒みたいに固定して変わること不可能な経典みたいな教えはないんだからね
聖書に対しての教えは何もないんだからね
だから彼は日々良いいい宗教を作っているんですよ
ですから  それはいいことだと思いますよ
で 例えばスリランカのキリスト教の人々は
昔は我々は悪魔のグループで異端者で潰すべきだと
今は仲間にするならば
先に仏教を仏教をやとということになっているんですね
だからまあ 一番トップの神父さんいますからね
カーディナルさんがね
もうお坊さんと同じなお友達はお坊さんたちなんですね
カトリック教のトップの方はね
我々も全然なんかお坊さんたちの友達よっていう感じで
我々の他宗教のトップやだから
こいつは潰さなくちゃっていうことじゃないんです
すごく丁寧に大事にしている
だからまあ キリスト教自体が変わって変わっていくんですよ
より緩和的で より人間的になって変わっていくんで
この神っていうのは創造神という概念があったでしょ
それでくたくた 科学者もそれを批判しましたし
ありえないと言っていたし
そうすると今はじわじわと法則にすべてを司る法則に改良しつつなんですね
それが変わったら 私たちにも文句を言うことできなくなっちゃうんですね
それで違うところは あなた方は法則にすがろうと思っている
我々は法則を脱出しようとしている
それだけ違いますよと言えることになります
それで愛の定義なんですけど
当然最初はキリスト教は人間だけ愛した
最初は自分の仲間だけ愛したんですね
神を信じる仲間のグループの人に対して
他は野蛮人で殺しても大丈夫と
で 戦争まで意欲をした
それは改良して やっぱり人間愛することにしましょうと
それも改良して 今は動物を守るためにも我々よりうるさいね
あの連中は 私たちは動物を守っていたのに
だから私はうるさいというのは冗談で可愛いんだから言ってるだけ
お前らいつだってうるさいなと言いたいところだけなんで
仲間だからそう言えるしね
で 例えば老人ホーム作ったり
年寄りの面倒を見ましょうと
我々はジェズスの愛を実践しているんだと
これは仏教徒はね 何もやってないんですよ
私たちはやってないよと
我々に老人ホーム入れませんと
私たちにとっては年取ったおじいさんというのは宝物だと
尊敬に値するんだと だから朝手を合わせて挨拶しますよと
老人ホームを入れる？入れられませんよ
こんな尊い宝物 いつでも孫たちのことを心配して
自分には何もできないくせに
いろんなことを教えてあげたりしているんだから宝物なんですね
それで仏教徒の世界では
障害人が持っちゃうと
病人の看病をすることはお釈迦様の教えをすることと同じく徳があるんだっていうことで
すごく面倒見見てあげる
だから施設はいらなくなっちゃう
だからお前がうるさいと言うだけ
で終わっちゃうんですね
しかし スリランカでも現代時代になっちゃうと
まあ老人ホームも必要になっているんです
何としましょうか お坊さんたちの老人ホームがあります
だからスリランカでやるときはもうちょっとおかしいですね
やりすぎ でもあれだけ戦いでもなんでもないです
そういうことで あのキリスト教の慈しみも
今は大体生命まで広げるではないかなと思っているんですね
で だから彼らが不殺生戒もね
やっぱり守らなくちゃね
まあ聖書には殺すだけなんですけど
これはあの優秀ホモサピエンスだけ人を殺すことだけで解説してるんですね
イナガミ単車を殺していたんだから
そういうことでいろいろそんな差なんですね
それからキリスト教は愛という単語を使うんだけど
心理学的に愛とは何ぞやと分析していない
一般的に感情でね 子供を愛すると
自分の子供をね 気持ちいい
それだけに留まっている奥さんを愛すると
すごい気持ちいい  そんな程度だけ拡大する
それはちょっと拡大できませんよ
我が子を愛する感情がね
拡大しちゃうとまずい
ではなくて この慈しみという生命をことごとく慈しむということは
僕は智慧使っています
生命 誰だって生きる権利がある
それに基づいて権利を認めましょう
権利とは侵してはならないもの
侵した人が悪人ですということで
我々は自由の実践をします
そういうところなんですね
似ていないところはね
わざわざ似ていないところを探す必要もないんだけどね
まあ仏教は完全に語っているんだからね
どうせ似ていないでしょ
他宗教の方々は私たちのところまで進化してこなくちゃいけないんですね
進化しないイスラム教に対しては何とも言えませんだけどね
はい 以上です  はい そろそろ時間なんですけど
もう一人ぐらい大丈夫
よろしくお願いします
最近連日ニュースになってるんですけれども
北朝鮮の人たちのように
人たちというか 多分上の人だけだと思うんですけれども
ああいうふうに人の話を聞かないで
自分の権利だけを主張するような人たちに対して
どんなふうに どうしたらいいでしょうか
あの どうする必要もないんですね
考えるだけで気持ち悪いでしょ
すると私の心が汚れるんですね
だから管轄外にしてください
考えるだけで腹が立ちますからね
一方的に世界に向かって人を馬鹿にしたい放題
侮辱したい放題 それからニュースタイムズ冊子でね
トランプとウンさんがお互い貶し合うの上手だと
それでトランプがウンさんを貶す
ウンはトランプを世界貶すセクションいろいろ TWITTER でね
書いてるものを出して記事がありましたけどね
ネットでしか見てない冊子まだあるんだけど
そこは調べてないんだけど
そういうわけでね 世の中でわがままだけで
自分だけ正しいって思ってるバカもいるんだから
そんなことを考えると自分も気持ち悪くなっちゃって
自分の心が汚れて 自分が関係ないことで罪を犯しちゃうんですね
だから関係ないことでなんで罪を犯す？そういうことで無関心態度が一番いいと思いますね
聞いてないよと 北朝鮮が日本人がネズミや犬猫と
そう聞いてないんだけどね
別に痛くも痒くもないんだからね
しかし あんな凶暴でいくと
宇宙法則によって潰れなくちゃいけないんですね
木でもあまりにも高く伸びちゃうと台風で折れなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからそれは自然法則に任せてください
どうせ今度の台風でこの木の上のところ折れますよと
だったらわざわざ登ってそのところで切ってあげて
面倒くさいですね そういうことで
ああいう方々 ああいう国々は自然法則によって
まあなるべきようになります
だから北朝鮮だからといって法則は超えられませんだからね
あんな汚い傲慢な心を持っちゃうと足元見えなくなります
今も足元見えてないんだからね
だから私たちはそこに手を染める必要はないんです
抑止必要ない 手と言ったって心ですね
どうぞ勝手に頑張ってくださいという感じでいた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい 以上です  はい では最後に
お話ありがとうございました
ちょっとだいぶ個人的な話になってしまうんですけども
今日の話の結論としては
今日一日一日のことに集中してするっていうことだと思うんですけども
私 会社員で 時には長期的にどういうふうに計画
何か計画立ててくださいみたいな場面が出てきていて
そういう時にこれは無常だから
今日一日のことを気を立てなさいとか
そういうことはなかなか言えなくてですね
そういうところをどううまくやって
周りと協調し 協調していけばいいかっていうですかね
どううまくやっていきます
お願いします この世は何でも無常だと思ったら
人には長期的な計画を作れますよ
だからこれはバカに言ってね
笑わせる必要ないしね
だから自分がちゃんと
まあこれ計画っていうのは紙の上だけでしょうね
結局は だから想定して想定して想定して
この条件はこうであるならば
この条件は固定して変わらないならばこうなりますよということでしょ
どうせどんな計画立ててもそううまくいくわけじゃないんで
だからそれは人に言う必要はないんです
だからリラックスして長期的な計画
計画書を書いて出す 実行に移ったら日々それ改良しなくちゃいけない
これを別にいいんじゃない
そんなもんだからね いつだって
だから昔も今も これからの人生はそういう風になるんです
会社でも同じことでしょう
無常に逆らえる馬鹿がいないんです
だからあんた気楽に長期的な計画を考えて書いて出してください
別にどうったことないんです
しかし ご自分がこんな固定した条件はないんだということだけ知っておいてください
いつでもこのなんか間をあけて
間というんですかね あの
条件変わるかもというところもちょっと考えた方がよろしいんですね
それだけです 世界っていうのは
この株 証券売買やってる場所と同じく
何が起こるかわからない
例えば証券取引の場合は
ほんのちょっと噂で それもただの噂で
ものすごい株でしょ 例えばイランにアメリカが攻撃するんだという噂を流しただけで
株商売がね もうあちゃむちゃ乱れちゃうんで
でも攻撃はしなかったんですね
そんな程度の連中ですよ
この一番トップで経済をねじっているのはウォールストリートで一番バカな連中なんですね
だから ちょっとした噂を見て
ちょっとした世間の状況
まだ本当はそうならない
それによってもう株の値段が上がったり下がったりね
大破壊したり 大損害を受けたり
いろいろ起きますよ だから超一流ともそうなんですから
あなたは別にそこまで切る必要ないでしょうに
そういうことで 長期的な計画を立てて書いてください
考えてください 別にそれはもちろんです
それはまあ自分では執着しないということに役に立ちます
計画はうまくいったら楽しいし
いかなかったら別にっていうことでリラックスしていられます
そんな考えであります
あまり気にすることじゃないです
はい  はい ありがとうございました
では じゃあ最後の一方
はい 今日は貴重なご講演
どうもありがとうございました
今日の話題とはちょっと外れると思うんですけれども
単刀直入にお聞きしたいんですが
結婚する場合ですね どういう視点で相手を選んだらいいんでしょうか
若い時に結婚することが多いと思うので
やっぱり恋愛感情で好き嫌いっていうことで
やっぱり相手に執着するしないっていう視点で
すごく執着して好きになって
相手とお互い同じ気持ちになれば結婚するっていう形になるとは思うんですけれども
やっぱり長い結婚生活 20年
30年って歩んでいく中で
やっぱりお互い気持ちが違うとか
そういうのがわかってきて
なかなかこう 歳を取ってからもとても仲がいい夫婦っていうのが
熟年離婚とかが今多いって言われてますけれども
あんまりいないなって思うので
その結婚する相手を見極めるポイントっていうのがあれば教えていただきたいなと思います
答えは質問の中にありますね
結婚するのは若い人でしょ
何も人を理解できない年で
人のことを判断できない年で
感情で生きている 感情真っ最中で生きている一番バカな年なんですね
だから我々にとっては若い子っていうのはすごく楽しいんですよ
やること何でもバカなことばっかしやって
それでも楽しく生きてるんですね
だから年寄りにはそんなバカなことできないんでしょ
でも あの連中がすごい楽しく生きることは楽しいんですね
だから そういう人生の中でね
一番理解能力最低な時
みんな結婚するんだから
結論は誰の結婚もうまくいってないってことなんですね
笑い 誰も結婚相手探したときって判断が間違ったっていうことなんです
それでみんな間違ってるんだったらどうってことないでしょ
かえって 別にいいんです
別に 誰も自分に合わない人と結婚してますよ
そういうことで そこもすごい気楽によろしいんです
しかし ポイントはあります
犬猫でも蹴ってはいけませんね
それは力んですよ 殺生は当然ダメでしょ
そこで人間同士で暴力振るう性格悪い人は捨ててください
男性だけじゃないよ 女性も結構暴力
暴力振るいますからね
だから男性の暴力 女性の暴力の違うところは
男性は １ 分で力強い 女性は ３ 時間で力弱い
どちらでも ３ 時間ぐらいやられると相当効きますよ
で それだけできることならね
若い子たちがいろいろテストしてね
自分の恋人をね 暴力振るか振らないか
突然怒るか怒らないか
それだけチェックしてみてください
突然怒るんだったら 私はあなたもすごく好きでしたけど
つけくださいなの だからどちらもテストしてみてください
だいたい暴力振る場合は男性の方が数が多いんだからね
ですから 結婚する前にそのテストだけやってみて
暴力振るか振らないか
それから 正しい結婚生活したければこうするんです
この人は変わらないんだと
何やっても だから人を変えること無理だからやめてください
これが女性でしょ 結婚ですごく悩むのはその点で男を改良して改造して
自分好きなようにプログラムしようとするんですね
これできない だからそれをやめる
男もそうなんです 自分の女を自分好きなように変えようとするんですね
女がずるいんだから なんか変わったような顔を見せるんですね
でも決して変わってないんですよ
男は下手だから変わったような顔を見せないんですね
だからそこを大事なポイントで
結婚してから死ぬまで
二人は二人でそれぞれの人格を持っている
我々 どんどん慣れちゃえばいいんです
慣れるんです 慣れてしまえば
お互い対立は起きません
だから 幸せな結婚の秘訣とは
相手の性格に慣れてしまう
自分の性格を変える必要はないんです
相手にも自分の性格に慣れてもらいます
それで一人一人の独立性も個性も人権も守りつつ
二人が友達で仲良く一緒にいる
これ 友達ということは
友達は相手に説教しないでしょ
本当に友達っていうのは
相手のことを認めちゃう
まあ嫌だったら言うんだけど
お前こんなことやるんだけどね
面倒くさいんだけどとか
でもやめなさい こんなのはないんですね
だからだいたい友達っていうのは
お互いのいいところも長所
短所をよく知っているんですね
そこで守ってあげなくちゃいけないところを守ってあげる
叱ってあげなくちゃいけないところは叱ったりするし
しかし 相手完全に変えて自分好きなロボットにはならないんですね
だから結婚失敗するのは
お互い相手を自分のロボットにしようとしているんですね
男は女をロボットにしようとしているし
女が男をロボットにしようとしているし
これ永久的にそれにならないし
だからずっと不幸な結婚生活をするんですね
それより忙しい子供が生まれてくるわ
子供を学校に連れていかなくちゃ
いろんなことあるんだから
仕事がね それぞれ自分の仕事で忙しくて
相手の性格に慣れてみる
相手は変えようとしない
その代わりに相手のことを心配する友達になる
正しい結婚というのは
ものすごい素晴らしい友達同士なんですね
...だから自分の不平不満があったらまあへっちゃらでいるし
相手の不平不満をよく優しく聞いてあげたりするという友達同士なんですね
そういうことで まあなんでこれどうしても若い時結婚するんだからね
頭がよく咲いている時は年取ってるんだから
もう結婚も時間も飛んでいるんですね
これは私がやったことじゃないんだからね
世間はそうなっているんです
だから人類はいつでも合わない人と結婚するようになってるんです
これはどうしようもないんです
しかし 後から考えれば
なんでこの人と これは縁があるんですね
だから逃げられませんね
だから縁があるということも考えてください
縁があるというのは お互いにスタディする
相手の性格の違うところを勉強して
自分の人格を向上する
相手に合わせません それでお互い様
まあケーススタディとしてね
人を学ぶ ケーススタディで自分の伴侶を研究材料にする
研究材料はいじったり変えたりしないでしょう
そのままどうなっているのかでスタディすることだからね
結婚の場合はそんな程度ですね
言えるのはね 大丈夫です
はい では これで本日の講演会を終了いたします
最後に祈願の言葉を皆様でお唱えして終了いたします
はい 一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェニンドゥッカ
バヤッパッタチェニンバヤ
ソウカッパッタチェニッソウカ
ホントゥサンベティパニド
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しむなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]